orange is the new black your character
has a lot of tats do you get those put
on you have you have a tab that says no
no I have this that's that's all my ink
I have this mic on so yeah that's all
right
gentleman and help me out yeah I can't
believe your relationships don't work
[Applause]
Butler yeah yeah somebody is butch right
there yeah
all right that's right yeah I asked for
[ __ ] it just yeah it's just gonna say
butch for the rest of my life all right
quickly DUI I was gonna ask you about
the Super Bowl because I asked bill do
you care who wins a Super Bowl
hello lesbian even ask me something like
that about sports as I hate crime care
about soccer ball team what can I ask
you about sports here well are you gonna
ask me about anything you what yeah I'm
flying today hey let me help before you
[Applause]
what is routine football what's your
team do you like Yankee Oh
have you thank you gun this thing can
hear everyone here is gonna see I swear
I saw Joe with Bilbo
you're going to see a Yankees game I can
go all the time yeah
that must be nice to get the celebrity
treatment I do the best thing that ever
happened to be I have to tell you was so
I go there and I bought really expensive
tickets shocking at Yankee Stadium but I
bought really expensive tickets and I
started to go to this VIP bar and they
were like your tickets will let you into
the VIP bar like really good cuz I'd
spent a lot and the woman who is like
checking the tickets like staring at me
so I'm like yes yes Swiss you look
really familiar
so you know I don't generally do this
but to get into a VIP bar with free hot
dogs at the Yankee Stadium I'm going so
I said yeah I play big food orange is
the new black just yeah that's not it
[Laughter]
weren't you on Matlock I recurred on
Matlock for two years you remember two
year two seasons this is like in the 90s
like the early nineties yeah so I got
into the VIP bar because I worked with
Andy Griffith
[Applause]
causing
you